why I said emotional resilience tool for
mental health people talk to eyes up
when they don't want to talk to another
human being originally what we were
trying to do was detect depression using
sensor data from a phone we found that
very few people had actually been able
to access help but many of them had been
using the chat board and had found it
helpful and that's when the idea of
Weiser came about detection isn't enough
you have to actually help people I've
been using Weiss with my patients for
two maybe two and a half years now why
it really helps people to reflect and
learn more about themselves their own
well-being and the things they can do to
strengthen their well-being initially
there's this chat based function that
allows you to be really reflective in
quite a safe and secure way because you
know it's anonymous and you know there's
no judgement but then it also offers
modules and support we had a mom a new
young girl who came to see us who were
both quite anxious every day things
would start a bit of a worry and it was
starting to feel really overwhelming for
them we got them both to use worser the
younger learned I'm not about things to
help her feel less anxious so she got in
the habit of sitting in her seat
having maybe 30 seconds a minute
mindfulness moment before she'd give a
class presentation and that really
helped her and mum particularly noticed
a massive improvement colleagues at work
we're commenting on how much more
relaxed she was her life had completely
changed and she felt much more able to
do things with her daughter and really
achieve at what she wants to do
technology can be a huge enabler in
helping people understand that you can
support your own mental health and
technology will change the way we look
after ourselves you're trying to make
the world more mentally resilient
technology has always been seen as a
part of the problem and now we want to
make it the solution
you
[Music]